'icarly it's a hilarious show but you
know what's even funnier than what we
see on screen everything we don't see
bloopers can be amazing and the ones
from iCarly are no different just try to
keep a straight face while watching
these the cast of the show has always
seemed like very funny individuals and
these bloopers prove it but who do you
think cracked the most well filming the
show was it jennette mccurdy nathan
kress or is it Jerry Trainor
let's get started you started a fire at
the fire department Wow yeah we don't
know how the cast kept it together
through a lot of the show's most
hilarious moments and it's clear how
much fun they all had filming the show
just look at this scene where Jerry
Trainor comes in dressed as a mom to one
of the stars Jerry always seems like a
larger-than-life presence but the way he
storms in it's impossible for the rest
of the stars not to break it's capped
off by an extremely funny outburst
directed at Freddie which we think ties
it all together this one is one of our
favorites icarly often called for some
wacky props so it's only reasonable to
think that sometimes things got out of
hand
this blue perceives Jerry trying to open
a safe in the living room with a
blowtorch
and let's just say things don't go as
planned what makes it even funnier is
Jerry yelling with this steak only to
blow it shortly after because of his
limited vision it's okay Jerry if we
were wearing those goggles we wouldn't
be able to see either have you ever
tried to talk with a mouth full of food
we have to say it's not easy it's even
harder when you have to act along with
it kudos to jennette mccurdy and nathan
kress for trying their best to keep it
going but it proves to be too much for
them to handle this scene calls for
Jeanette's Sam to talk with food in her
mouth but whoever wrote that in the
script probably didn't appreciate how
hard that was to do in execution
and Nathan's little quip afterwards is
just icing on the cake if there's any
star that seems like the king of
bloopers it's Jerry Trainor Jerry just
brings such an infectious and fun energy
and you can tell he's super passionate
about his work he seems very much like
the character he plays the next scene
has Jerry pretending to go off on
Miranda and screaming about his current
working conditions the absolute best
part about this is the crew member
standing next to Jerry basically
ignoring everything Jerry's yelling
about which tells us this isn't the
first time Jerry has caused the scene
like this sometimes laughter is
infectious and can't be stopped just
look at this scene where Jerry Spencer
is wheeled to the table next to Sam you
could tell everyone involved is having
trouble keeping a straight face and it
wasn't long before the floodgates broke
almost literally in this case Jeanette
sees Jerry's start to laugh and
immediately does a spit-take this of
course causes everyone else - laughs -
we just feel sorry for whatever piays
job it was to clean up the mess
afterwards we think after this blooper
you won't be able to get the phrase how
did this happen out of your head
so good luck the cast of iCarly grew to
be great friends while filming and it
shows in bloopers like this when Miranda
Nathan and Jeanette laugh about the way
Miranda said a certain phrase it's just
nice to see Miranda is just as able to
laugh at herself as her friends are at
her that's the sign of a truly special
cast and we got to say Nathan's
impression is spot-on
one of iCarly's standout characters is
Gibby
played by Noah Munck and although he
doesn't seem to have as many bloopers as
the rest of the cast Noah still looks
like he had a blast on set this next
blooper isn't a long one but it does
highlight the gibby character in the
best way as noah spinned in the chair
with miranda next to her he can't help
but giggle as he tries to deliver his
signature get flare take a look for
yourself and you'll see did Miranda have
any unresolved onset tension with Jeri
probably not because the two seem to
have gotten along great but based on
this next blooper it seems that deep
down Miranda really wanted to smack Jeri
while the two are talking
Miranda's character takes a towel and
randomly hits Jeri with it surprising
both of them in the process
Gary's look to the camera afterwards is
the perfect picture of confused amused
and maybe even a little scared we're not
even sure how something like this next
one even happens but the only way to
describe it is a major wardrobe
malfunction during a scene where Miranda
had to reach into her pocket her hand
caught on her dress and the dress just
wouldn't let go my hand sucks we think
the dress just really liked Miranda's
ring and wanted to keep it for itself it
was caught so bad that Miranda had to
call in someone to help her remove it do
you think there's a professional unstick
err on set who handles things like this
we hope so in Jerry's defense it's a
catchy song to dance to but who knew
Jerry had such great moves in the
episode where Jerry really amps up his
pranks there's a scene where he dances
in victory but even when the camera
stops rolling Jerry just keeps going and
can't be stopped and we're certainly not
complaining we would watch an entire
episode of iCarly just with Jerry
dancing his heart out and we'd still
love it wouldn't you next time we're out
partying we're definitely going the
Jerry dance okay be honest if you had to
deliver any of Spencer's lines in the
next iCarly looper could you possibly
keep a straight face we think his
blueberry line is so funny that we could
barely keep it together ourselves so
just think how hard it was for him to
actually say it
oh and a blueberry have a childhood is
that child called
a blue and the great thing about this
fun blooper is how much the whole cast
gets involved whether it's messing up a
line are not being able to open the
weird doors properly it looks like
everyone got involved who knew acting
needed so much coordination we thought
it was just simply memorizing lines and
then saying their lines but now you're
telling us the actors have to be
coordinated and catch things thrown at
them too that's too much well maybe not
all the time but it definitely is
overwhelmed Jeannette in this blooper
when her character was supposed to run
and catch stuff thrown at her by Freddy
and the real joy is knowing that she not
only missed the catch the first time but
at least one more time after that
hey whoever said acting was easy we'd
like to see anyone keep a straight face
after being flung from a couch while
pretending to sleep so overall Nathan
gets some serious props for even
attempting to keep the scene going but
you could just tell this scene broke him
both as an actor and as a person
well his character sleeps on the couch
Sam tips the couch over after getting
permission from Carly Nathan falls off
but it looks like that couch might have
been heavier than Sam thought because
she has trouble pulling it back the next
icarly blooper doesn't need a full
introduction it speaks for itself or
else tries to that is even the most
skilled actor semester fly-ins every so
often it's usually because someone is
speaking too fast or trying to do too
much at the same time and that seems to
happen here but we got to agree with
Miranda
sometimes there's still a show to do so
it's best to move on quickly and try
again the show goes we say stupid stuff
and do stuff if only the rest of the
iCarly was as good as getting over
bloopers like Miranda picture the most
romantic kiss you can think of yeah this
blooper might just top them all okay
we're kidding because there's no way you
could consider this an actual kiss while
his arm is around her Sam and Freddie
look super cute together
and when Sam goes for a kiss on the
cheek she ends up growling and blowing
raspberries instead it's probably not a
very romantic moment but at least it's
funny
and Nathan certainly looks amused during
it
hey just because it's a fake person
doesn't mean we shouldn't feel bad for
it our heart strings were pulled in this
Bluebird when the casts mistake causes
the mannequin to fall over and basically
break or mannequin what did it ever do
to deserve such a fate oh well at least
it was for a good cause and by that I
mean obviously making us laugh until our
sides hurt the best part is how the cast
all freezes right after it falls as if
not sure if they should keep going or
call cut although acting on such an
amazing show seems like the best job in
the world we can't forget how hard these
actors work to deliver us hilarious
episode after hilarious episode you're
only human after all they get tired just
like the rest of us the best example of
this is the blooper which sees the
cameras swing over to Nathan only to
have Nathan being caught mid yon talk
about embarrassing he quickly tries to
shoo the camera away exciting how it's
not supposed to come to him yet now this
blooper maybe a little staged but it's
still such a funny moment to watch
mainly because Nathan and Jeannette are
so funny together the whole point of
this blooper is that Jeannette can't say
one word right and the two take it to
the extreme by manically laughing until
their sides hurt everything about this
blooper is great the laughter of the
costumes and just the general setup of
the whole thing but let's be honest who
hasn't messed up an easy word from time
to time there's such a thing as
spreading a joke into the ground enough
until it eventually becomes funny again
and that's the general gist of this
blooper it builds off the joke of the
last blooper with Sam unable to say the
word fish properly but this time their
surprise guest Jerry who interrupts the
two of them then they all laugh
hysterically and maybe it's because
Jerry automatically makes every scene
he's in better but it turns this already
funny blooper into something truly
amazing
hey Sam we get it if we dropped a
platter of quesadillas we'd be
devastated too we think there's nothing
more rewarding in the world than a nice
piping hot quesadilla platter which is
why we were so sad to see Sam drop it
but behind the scenes the actors playing
Sam and Nathan tried their best
keep the scene going so that proved
impossible although Sam adapted to
grabbing some floor food and running
Nathan just couldn't keep a straight
face as he watched Sam dropped the
precious cargo
well that's a wrap on this video
well blooper made you laugh the hardest
let us know in the comments below and
while you're there don't forget to hit
that big subscribe button for more
awesome content like this thanks for
watching the things everyone see you
next time